[Music]
five republican candidates for nevada
governor going head to head tonight in a
debate right here on 8 news now each
answering questions on a range of topics
making their case ahead of the primary
i can fix nevada the debate was
respectful for the most part but got
heated when the issue of crime and
illegal immigration was brought up i
support
legal immigration i do not support
illegal immigration and i am the only
one standing up here at this podium that
has removed anybody who has committed
crimes associated with and being
undocumented illegal within the state of
nevada sheriff lombardo you know we
refer to him among us as sanctuary joe
for a reason department of justice
inspector general's report 2016 had
clark county is one of the worst
sanctuary counties in the nation but
let's let's be clear joe's not telling
the truth here
what happened when he made southern
nevada a sanctuary city i think even the
trump justice department were thinking
about suing him over doing this and yet
he denies he ever did it so anyway
that's why i called him out and i think
that uh the fact that homicides are up
uh almost 50 percent and by you know
violent crimes up 45 percent yeah i
don't think we want to bring that up to
northern nevada overall the candidates
were pleased with their debate
performances people got a glimpse of
what what they could expect from a
governor especially from me and for me i
liked it i like to be able to get up
there i wish we'd been there for another
hour we have the least name recognition
so we had to make an impact and we i
think we made an impact by being
different i want the residents of
northern nevada to know that we're going
to work together the southern area with
the northern area and we're going to
work with the rurals this is one
wonderful state everybody pays taxes
everybody deserves services and i'm
going to offer that to everyone in this
state of nevada sheriff lombardo has
momentum behind him because nevadans
know he has the leadership and
experience that they can trust to get
our state back on track after syslax
failed policies in fact in his closing
remarks sheriff lombardo turning his
attacks on governor sisilak let's be
honest with each other for all practical
purposes this primary is over
there's nothing more to argue about i've
weathered 12 months of attacks from
steve syslag in his packs and for most
of the individuals standing here next to
me
and why why why have i been able to work
weather them they're all bogus they're
not working
governor steve sisilak campaigned
responding to the debate tonight on
channel 8 saying in part no republican
candidate running for governor has the
experience plan or temperament needed to
move nevada forward he added that each
is making promises that would move our
state backwards now you can watch the
full debate the hour-long debate find
everything you need to know about the
upcoming primary posted to eight newsnow
dot com